hallo mein name ist luca und als ich
diese musik ist das etwa ein firma 3
falls ihr euch noch an die letzte folge
da könnt ihr könnt ihr wahrscheinlich
nicht weil ich schon circa sieben jahre
her ist
jedenfalls sind wir an einer stelle
stehen geblieben wir sind ganz nah am
ziel
schnell war okay und ich bin dann ein
bisschen ausgerastet
jedenfalls habe ich gerade so viel
weiter gespielt dass ich wieder beim
jackpot ohne witz ich bin hier beim
check point und wenn ich mal hier rüber
springen ihr seht ihr schon nach rechts
hier das ist diese stelle wo ich auch im
part 2 war das heißt ich habe wirklich
gerade im schaumbad wie viele tore habe
ich dafür gebraucht ich habe 62 tote
habe ich 62 versuche habe ich vor diesem
video hier gebraucht um überhaupt an
diese stelle zu kommen damit das
ausgegebene storyline damit wir genau da
weitermachen also wenn das nicht ein
geiler youtuber hier ist er da wir
versuchen das ganze jetzt zu schaffen
also hierhin hier ein bisschen wie sowas
da es war klar
vitali ich höre euch irgendwann steht
hier alles voll mit irgendwelchen
figuren dann hole ich mir noch mario
dazu ich habe echt bock das ganze hier
so wieder als als seriöser wissens macht
teil eins gemacht
bleibt ruhig ich habe teil eins gemacht
und dachte mir wirklich nachteil
nach teil eins dachte ich mir eigentlich
will ich habe dann teil 2 allerdings
erst des mega viel staub ich will einer
putzen und habe mir danach teil 2
gedacht ja dann nimmst du auch mal ein
paar drei auf jetzt die tage jetzt hat
wieder irgendwie mal ein paar monate
gedauert ich hab das war jetzt aber bock
das richtig ich spiele jetzt einfach
aber wir haben natürlich gar kein
problem damit
ich bin extra stehen geblieben
okay wir sind hier und ich werde jetzt
wenn der darüber schnell rüber das war
ich bin hier ich springe ich darüber und
ich gehe genau genau genau okay jetzt
[Musik]
mein gott so weit waren wir noch nie ich
weiß genau dass jeder einzelne sprung
fatal sein könnte das heißt ich springe
einfach um mein gott ok mit den nächsten
vertraulich okay das von medien für den
von euch nicht den
jetzt sind wir hier jetzt hier schnell
heuer
[Musik]
die greenstream ist das game
rihanna wenn man sich konzentriert muss
man das eigentlich schaffen also jetzt
hier über jetzt hier drauf genau jetzt
hier erstmal hier drauf hier drüber okay
hier kann nicht drauf ok auf diesen
wären nämlich richtig dieser hier war
richtig dieser hier muss auf sicht da
ist das hier da ist das hier freunde das
ziel die anspannung steigt bitte bitte
lass mich einfach ins ziel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin im ziel ich will complete bisher
ist es echt so in part 1 haben wir level
1 gemacht und hat 22 und jetzt gewinnen
wir das ding einfach komplett was
passiert wenn ich hier nach hinten da
war auch schon so ein kleines ziel aber
ich denke da kommt man nicht hin oder
her kommt man nicht kann ich nicht einen
doppelsprung oder so raus wohne ich muss
das doch irgendwie schaffen
o rama.com luca nein okay das war falsch
okay jetzt wird das weiterkommen kann
man okay kommt es auf die richtige art
und weise wie soll ich das denn schaffen
will dieses spiel mich eigentlich
komplett verarschen die soll ich das
denn schaffen
[Musik]
gaildorf ok ich muss einfach das weiß
eigentlich nur durch einen fehler von
mir aber okay okay wenn der mir da oben
schon sagt wohl voll da und juda wird
safe nicht rund na gut vielleicht blüten
die dann auch mal nicht hier in die
mitte hierhin ok und jetzt ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob ich da oben drauf kann
ich probier's einfach mal okay ich bin
drauf okay ist dahinter ist ein
checkpoint das heißt jungs gefällt euch
das eigentlich oder wollen wir auch mal
spielen ja ich bin vitello ich kann euch
das ganz simpel zeigen wie das geht und
zweige ich einfach nur hierhin jetzt
die hier drauf genau hierhin jetzt ob
ich hier hin weil die anderen fall davon
ja cool ich bin einfach hier
na ja genau ich mach das mal eben hier
zusammen mit ihr genauer an und springt
sie mich hierhin dann kann sie hier wird
was kannst du das ziel für heute ist
einfach zum checkpoint zu kommen der
checkpoint bringt uns eh nichts beim
alten level war der jackpot auch nicht
mehr da soll ja jetzt hier ab in die
mitte
hierüber genau hier drauf wie konnte ich
das vergessen hier in die mitte von der
insel hier drauf hier ein ganz langer
sprung in die mitte hier drauf hier ein
ganz langer sprung genau jetzt hier
drauf jetzt hier runter okay hier
drunter her
wahrscheinlich muss jetzt geschehen okay
okay ich weiß auf jeden fall schon mal
wie ich bis dahin durchkommen weil da
kann ich einfach hier so lange laufen
bin dann dementsprechend steigen die
nicht auf da bin ich auch wieder
gestorben gerade wie sie bei 111 toten
ich sage mal einfach wenn wir 130 sind
ist dass sie dir vorbei kann ihn nicht
einfach warten ist dieser blog da hinten
bei dem anderen genau da hinten
angekommen ist oh mein gott als ok ich
muss jetzt irgendwie ich weiß nicht wie
muss ich als safe drauf da ist das ziel
dass das hier
es ist doch los ich will einfach nur da
hinten sein okay das teil das jetzt
weiter
bezüglich um die lass es mich noch
einmal versuchen ich bin bei den gumpert
ich weiß dann noch nicht was ich dazu
sagen soll ob ich einfach weil ich werde
das in diesem video noch schaffen das
kann noch nicht allzu schwer sein
einfach um diese verdammten scheiß kumba
sie herum man das ist doch man das kann
doch nicht so schwer sein ich hab
einfach hier jetzt warte ich nicht dass
er hier ist und hier war ja nicht zum
unfall genau ab hier rüber ich warte bis
er hier ist damit ich hierhin hüpfen
kaya das ist scheiße so kommt hier ruhig
hin ich hoffe einfach die haben ja okay
wir sind hier vorne ein langer damm
hierhin hierhin was habe ich wohl noch
mal falsch gemacht ich muss roten samt
machen
[Musik]
ich habe es geschafft mich angeschaut
und ich habe es geschafft ich habe es
geschafft ich habe es geschafft freuen
denn ich habe es geschafft hab das
nächste level und wurde folglich habe